the drug industry is starting the new
year by hiking the prices of hundreds of
prescription medications despite
pressure from President Trump a group
that tracks drug cost says about 60
companies increase the price on almost
300 medications the price of insulin a
life-saving drug for diabetics tripled
between 2002 and 2013 since 2008 three
top manufacturers raised the list price
of insulin at least ten times and a
Warner shows us one state's plan to rein
in soaring costs and one mother's
personal fight and a such an important
story good morning good morning bianna
the state of Minnesota is taking action
it's suing three of the world's largest
insulin manufacturers and a mother who
lost her son is telling her story and
saying enough my son died because he
could not afford his insulin Nicole
Smith Holt's son Alec was 26 he had just
moved out of his parents home and was
starting a life of his own the hardest
part is every time I tell the story it's
like reality slaps me in my face that my
son is no longer here Alec was a type 1
diabetic someone who needs to take
insulin every day to survive but turning
26 meant his parents insurance would no
longer cover the cost that amount of
money was $1,300 $1,300 for a month
his worth of insulin influence applies
and what she says Alec didn't tell her
was that he was struggling with that
cost he had started trying to ration his
insulin to make it last longer it wasn't
enough he died after falling into a
diabetic coma alone in his apartment
nobody to be there with them toppled his
hand or to call for help and then I
think about if he had never moved out if
he had lived at home somebody would have
you know seen the signs are you able to
not feel guilty no no and I'll probably
feel guilty every day for the rest of my
life but he didn't tell you didn't know
so you feel guilty you feel like you
should have known yeah
even though you couldn't have known
yeah how do you deal with that um I deal
with that by advocating for other type 1
diabetics I deal with my own grief and
my guilt by fighting for the lives of
others I think in America nobody should
lose their life because they can't
afford the cost of insulin
Lori Swanson is Minnesota Attorney
General
she's now suing the top-three insulin
manufacturers for what she calls
deceptive misleading and
misrepresentative list prices they've
raised the price of insulin by being in
cahoots with the pharmacy benefit
managers and having a secret price for
them that the public doesn't get so you
say in cahoots which makes it sound like
a bit of a racket
absolutely drug manufacturers typically
must negotiate with pharmacy benefit
managers or PBMs those PBMs are
middlemen in the pharmaceutical supply
chain Swanson alleges to make money
manufacturers set phony list prices that
are artificially high so they can offer
greater rebates to PPM's and still
maintain their profits the drug
companies can make the same amount of
money but by doing that they've created
this ever cascading cycle of higher and
higher drug prices and many aspects of
the process are secret
you mentioned transparency yet I noticed
in your lawsuit there are parts blacked
out there are I know and it's incredibly
frustrating and we're gonna be fighting
that because these companies claim that
certain information is trade secret that
it's confidential and they and only they
can see it so you're literally not able
to put those numbers into your lawsuit
exactly isn't that ridiculous it's a
public lawsuit filed in court but we
can't put the numbers in because they're
claiming it's a trade secret and that
nobody's entitled to know or see that
information the company's response eli
lilly and company told CBS news the
lawsuits claims are without merit novo
nordisk says the company is committed to
ethics and compliance and Santa Fe says
it provides significant rebates but that
unfortunately it seems these savings are
not consistently passed through to
patients in the form of lower co-pays or
coinsurance PBM certainly play a problem
here in the system I no doubt about it
but we sued the pharmacist
companies because ultimately it's their
product so you don't buy it when they
say well it's not really our fault no I
don't buy it at all neither does Nicole
Smith Holt who has turned her grief into
action we need your support last August
she told her story to senators in
Washington and in September she
protested outside Eli Lilly headquarters
you know my son is not a statistic he
would be here if his life-saving
medication was priced at a reasonable
rate Minnesota's attorney general Lori
Swanson leaves office on Monday but says
her successor plans to continue the
state's lawsuit FDA Commissioner Scott
Gottlieb says that the FDA is going to
be changing the way that they regulate
insulin moving forward but we don't know
what those changes at 1300 hours a month
in it there must be a lot of people
trying to ration and cerrar he is
certainly not the only one who's tried
to ration his insulin which is very very
risky as you can see yeah a bit
frustrating to see so many redactions -
right right talk about hardly Rita thing
yes I'm glad we've done this story I
can't everyone I know who has halfs
diabetes 1 diabetes told me that insulin
prices are going through the roof and
making very difficult for them alright
thank you